je me suis retrouvé au milieu d'une
baston et malheureusement j'ai pris un
mauvais rêve
[Musique]
bref tout le monde faisait la fête il
faisait pas trop attention donc j'ai
pris le trophée comme ça j'ai pu en
profiter le matin et faire une belle
photo avec mon fils et le lendemain
matin ils étaient tous en train de
m'appeler il et autres offertes
c'est vrai c'est vrai c'est vrai ils se
battaient à l'époque pour rihanna et
donc moi j'étais au milieu de tout ça en
boîte de nuit chez n'a rien à faire là
dedans mais bon je me suis retrouvé au
milieu d'une baston et malheureusement
j'avais pris un bout de verre mais c'est
vrai qu'à l'époque j'en rigolais pas
trop parce que je suis allée à l'hôpital
direct le lendemain je me suis fait
opérer mais mais maintenant oui
maintenant je rigole c'est sûr
c'est vrai que il jouait avec un de mes
coéquipiers qui s'appelait ronny turiaf
qui était mon coéquipier en équipe de
france et il joue avec au bio lakers et
il avait demandé d'apprendre un peu le
français pour pouvoir me déstabiliser un
peu prendre les play-offs ils du coup
quand et après ça comment
bah ça me fait rigoler il va tellement
loin il veut tellement gagner qu'il est
prêt à tout faire quoi pour avoir un
avantage
non
onze heures d'avion et j'ai fait tout de
suite un entraînement c'est vrai que je
n'ai pas été très bon au final
ouais m'a bousculé c'est vrai après
c'est un coach à la sévère qui sort de
l'armée donc à ce jour là bon il était
un peu
en direction est mais moi je n'ai jamais
mal pris parce qu'à la fin de la journée
c'est un des meilleurs coaches de
l'histoire de la nba et ils voulaient
gagner et moi je lui offrais max
il m'a pas engueulé en plein repas de
noël c'est juste qu'il m'a dit viens on
va regarder une vidéo alors que c'est
noël est en effet en mode cool et il
voulait quand même aller travailler quoi
j'ai joué contre thomas c'est lui qui me
l'a rappelé en plus quand je les revues
plus tard ce que j'étais allé voir à
houston et donc j'ai visité un peu son
son monde qui est quand même assez
incroyable à la nasa
et c'est lui qui m'a rappelé qu'on avait
joué l'un contre l'autre et c'est avec
moi j'avais un peu oublié
c'est vrai que le retard pour moi c'est
signe de respect et c'est vrai que dans
mon monde avec mes employés j'aime bien
que tout le monde soit l'heure c'est
vrai mais c'est pas trop dur avec tout
mon emploi du temps d'être à leur nom
j'étais alors aujourd'hui pour moi c'est
juste une question de discipline quoi
montrer du respect d'arriver à l'heure
parce que voilà il ya tout un truc et et
tu veux respecter respecter le timing
parce que moi je sais que quand on
organise des trucs bah j'aime bien tout
le monde soit à l'heure pour complice
voilà respecter programme
ben elle aurait vu le jour quand même
mais c'est vrai que je les ai un peu
beaucoup chambrer quand elle arrive
warfare c'est vrai
non je suis à la retraite
je sais pas s'il est le meilleur rappeur
en tout cas moi c'est cela que je
préfère après et c'est la musique légaux
et les couleurs tout le monde a des
choix différents
moi je suis très éclectique dans mes
choix le musée que j'écoute un peu tôt
mais c'est vrai que dans le rap français
c'est cela que je préfère
elle était venue nous voir jouer donc je
l'avais rencontrée en avec une photo
avec le trophée et c'est très sympa
eh ben tu es invité à la maison blanche
et donc j'ai pu le rencontrer à ce
moment là et c'est vrai que j'ai un peu
enfin j'étais pas très contents du
photographe qui en fait il avec une
photo et c'est une photo où j'ai les
yeux fermés donc j'étais un peu à peu
dégoûté
mais c'est vrai
c'est pendant la grève en nba on était
en greffant deux mois et donc lavées
d'essayer de revenir en france et donc
le but ce n'était pas de pénaliser mon
club donc j'avais joué pour le salaire
minimum
bah oui bien évidemment je suis vraiment
content aujourd'hui de pouvoir vivre
cette passion à fond parce que je
voulais pas le faire pendant que j'étais
en carrière et maintenant je suis en
retraite sportive
je peux la vivre pleinement
[Musique]